good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday happy
first day with jackie and claudia back
sitting in our studio i think since
december 2021 yes hi
hi
crazy to be back but it also feels like
no time has passed like everything is
just the same it's been three months
four months
since we've been here together but like
now it feels like that was no time at
all no that's what happens when you're
best friends like no time passes me yeah
yeah would you say i'm your best friend
yeah
we said this is that tick tock
yeah i mean you call me your best friend
one time so i've never said it unless
you said it first we sound exactly like
tricia yeah that's so funny well
yes you are my best friend even though i
think now you probably wouldn't consider
me your best friend because like you
have another best friend i have i have a
lot of best friends you're just like
that girl with like a million best
friends yeah but they're all related to
me so it's
same
so jackie is joining us very graciously
in studio we know your time is beyond
precious i'm sure your breasts are
swelling as we speak so thank you so
much for being here a month and a half
postpartum yet again setting an
unrealistic unrealistic standard for
women we can't thank you enough for
being here
you're welcome for being here if you're
looking for a realistic standard for
women we did a patreon episode yesterday
um claudia and i took all of your
questions about month one postpartum and
it was so funny just so real true if
you're you know going through that
season of your life if you're pregnant
or if you're thinking about it like i
just feel like there's a lot of
interesting factoids i agree i thought
it was extremely informative and i don't
even have a child have you been learning
a lot about postpartum and just like
motherhood you know i've definitely been
learning that i'm gonna take my time
getting there so this is like one of
those things it's not uh what are the
people say like baby fever tickling your
ovaries everyone is like are your
ovaries dying i'm like no i'm like i
love this child and i can't wait to just
like
give the child back to jackie when he
starts to cry you know yeah being an
auntie is so glorious for that reason
alone i feel like it's having the
opposite effect
where ovaries are like out at the club
my ovaries are on molly
yeah they're living it up yeah so if
you're looking for like hardcore
motherhood update we have a bunch of
patreons now this is the second one
you've done yeah with us so there's a
lot of breastfeeding content birth story
all up on the patreon and today we're
just gonna have fun we're gonna giggle
we're gonna be best friends yeah like we
always are oh yeah i feel like kind of
weird like it is weird it's weird just
like talking to you looking at you and
that's what happened yesterday too we
were podcasting on my bed we were so
close that was a weird thing but it is
weird like because we just talk and hang
out and now like we're like
no i'm like i really can't even look you
in the eyes like it's weird oh okay it's
not that
oh yeah no it's not that weird it's not
that it's good it's good plus plus
now that we're back together we can
sing we can sing speaking of sing i
watched american idol last night
um because there was nothing else on tv
and like i'm never gonna dislike
watching people sing because when
they're good it's amazing and when
they're bad it's just as good but i have
to say american idol
has really gone down the toilet like
there's no singing first of all it's
just like katie and lionel and luke
being morons like playing stupid games
karaoke like it was so stupid and like
one audition between every commercial
break like it was so much filler i don't
know how people like can stomach the
show it was painful that is painful and
there's like the bar is so low you know
it used to be like if you were kind of
good you might not make it like but this
time if you can hit one note in your
song they're like oh you have potential
let's send them to hollywood well there
are so many voice shows they've been on
for so many years if you do the math
like at a certain point you do start to
reach people like you go through
everyone who has a nice voice and now
like there's not a lot of people left to
have a decent voice who aren't famous
and haven't been on tv yet well also i
think with the advent of tick tock a lot
of people don't need to go on
american idol to get famous in their
singing advent of a lot of things yeah
like and also it's been a while since
you needed to go on american idol to
become america's idol but it's also been
a while since someone from american idol
became a huge star like i think the most
recent one a lot of people point to is
like gabby barrett but before that it
was like phillip phillips 10 years ago
yeah i mean i guess you have an
interesting definition of huge star
oh why i think phil phillips is a huge
star
i mean that album was a life-changing
album i i never said he wasn't the most
talented man to walk the earth because
he is because he is yeah but huge star
what do you think have you guys heard of
philip phillips okay but by the way 10
years ago
ten years ago
when he
he was a star like he was a star i agree
and he was just
no no you don't have to prove anything
to me
you have to prove it to everyone else
i think 10 years ago like when his debut
out like his debut album was a big hit
and it was amazing but i'm not saying
he's a star now no no by no stretch of
the imagination is he a star now okay
yeah i feel like with american idol you
can reach like actually a pretty decent
level of success compared to other shows
where like if i didn't watch the voice
test he's in i have no clue who won i
will never hear who won yeah the voice
is weird like it's like a talent show
nobody really becomes famous yeah well i
watched an amazing program last night
called siesta key and if you're sleeping
on the key like if you're taking a
siesta on siesta key don't talk to me
okay i'm 100 sleeping on it so good i
know it's so good and everyone is just a
star i know even when nothing's
happening like last night's episode like
it was just premium content it's just
like a beautifully made show beautifully
made show like everyone's ready to be a
reality star and they do the turnaround
pretty quickly and it's pretty relevant
it's really good stuff yeah if you're
looking for you know another beautiful
mindless show the key in my opinion to a
successful reality show is turnaround
time
amongst other things but yes it's huge
and that i think was one of the biggest
downfalls with the kardashian show
honestly
like we were rehashing [ __ ] that
happened 10 months ago yeah
and they said that their turnaround time
on the new hulu show is going to be so
quick but they've been filming for a
while and i haven't seen a drop yeah no
like we're going to be in april when we
watch it talking about snl which is
october that's a long time to me i'm in
agreement we have a lot of kardashian
stuff to talk about today because i need
to like share my thoughts on everything
that happened last week because
some crazy things happen so i mean i'm
ready to dive in i don't really have
much to update everyone on i've just you
know spent the weekend being a
disgusting piece of [ __ ] you know
thanks for the update we spent time
together so that was we did it it was
lovely and brew and do got to get
together the boys back
i thought it was from that so raven what
was that band that raven and chelsea
were obsessed with boys can you google
it boys we are the boys we are the boys
in motion we give you our devotion boys
that is bruno and theo they are the boys
in motion and they do give you our
devotion every day in every way yeah
love that for them yeah we could jump in
and on daily valley because i have
obviously places to go children to feed
person to see and today's monday which
means you are back for your second to
unburden yourselves we did it without oh
no
third third third okay we haven't done
it without you yet it's such a segment
that's so near and dear to my heart so
today's are pretty funny i read them
yeah i want to hear what everyone got
into this weekend okay how you
embarrassed yourselves love that for you
so without further a do
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
better help relationships take work
especially the most important one
the one you have with yourself a lot of
us will drop anything to go help someone
that we care about we'll go out of our
way to treat other people well but how
often do we give ourselves the same
treatment better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
over 2 million people have used better
help online therapy there's so many
different ways to invest in yourself
whether it's self-care taking yourself
out for a day of glitz and glam or
taking care of your mental health with
better help there's no reason that you
shouldn't start now today's episode is
sponsored by better help and the morning
toast listeners will get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com toast
that's b-e-t-t-e-r
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by air doctor clean air is one of
the fastest and easiest ways we can have
a positive impact on our health
make a new resolution in your life
that's impossible to break by improving
the quality of your indoor air with a
high quality air purifier and all you
have to do is breathe as the weather
gets colder we're spending more time
indoors and cold and flus are making the
rounds we can wash our hands keep our
germs at bay and stay healthy but what
about our air well that's where the air
doctor purifier comes in it's convenient
it takes the guesswork out of clean air
with its auto mode feature that users
that uses a laser sensor to detect air
quality and automatically adjust to the
correct filtration level there's no need
to worry about noise because their
exclusive professional whisper jet fans
are 30 quieter than the fans around in
ordinary air purifiers which means you
can run air doctor at the highest speeds
while still enjoying a peaceful home
environment i'm not gonna lie i didn't
believe in the power of an air purifier
for a while and ben was very much like
we need a purifier we need a purifier
and then we got the air dr one and it's
been in our house now for like two
months and i definitely can detect a
different quality of life quality of air
and i happen to love um
just like the fresh vibe like you can
walk into your house and you can feel
the difference than like your hallway
yeah i have one in my house and i've had
one for a few months it's amazing
especially if you are sensitive to
smells to my first trimester pregnant
ladies out there an air purifier is what
you need i love my air doctor so much
and i know i always say ben is always
coughing and like sniffing and that's
really a symptom of not having good air
so his nasal congestion his coughing his
sneezing his itchy nose watery eyes have
made an enormous improvement so that's
an improvement for me
a professional quality hepa air purifier
is recommended by leading medical
experts as an effective way to reduce
airborne germs viruses and protect your
home make sure you get an air doctor to
keep you and your family safe this
winter they come with a no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee so if
you don't love it just send it back for
a refund minus the shipping just go to
airdoctorpro.com and use the promo code
toast and you'll receive a 35 discount
on their classic air doctor 3000
purifier that's right 35 off but only if
you go to a i r d o c t o r p r o dot
com and use the promo code toast great
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our first story claudia chose the
stories today and i will be reciting
them so
if you hate them send all the hate my
way as you guys normally do
first story kanye west's grammy
performance has been axed due to
concerning online behavior kanye will no
longer be hitting the 2022 grammy stage
as a rep for the artist has confirmed
that his performance has been pulled due
to his quote concerning online behavior
variety confirmed the news shortly after
um his collaborative collaborator the
game took to social media in iran
defending kanye as he faces scrutiny for
harassing estranged wife kim cyber
bullying pete davidson and using a
racial slur while addressing trevor noah
um so this is where like an intersection
of my disdain for cancer culture but
also my annoyance with kanye have really
reached a peak because i don't believe
in cancer culture but like i'm so here
for this cancellation kanye's annoying
the [ __ ] out of me and the less i have
to see him honestly i think the better
for me personally yeah even though i've
been accused in our youtube comments
last week of promoting censorship i
can't people are so deranged honestly a
lot of the people who like are standing
kanye and like will not back down i just
so cannot understand like that headspace
whatsoever like clearly
kim is in the right here and kanye's in
the wrong so while i am against kinsell
culture i really right
but kanye's in the wrong what do the
grammys have to do with it i guess yeah
but like maybe he's like a loose cannon
and they don't know what the [ __ ] he's
going to say that's always been kanye
yeah but like it's reached a different
level now it definitely has
okay it's reached a peak
i mean to not have him sing his songs on
a stage because like of what he's
writing on social media well yeah i
guess like he just called trevor noah
the k word which is like psychotic even
though trevor noah tweeted i said
counsel kanye not canceled kanye so he's
not here for this either even though he
was technically one of the victims of
kanye's rants yeah i i don't know
because i haven't been like
reading everything that he's doing and
keeping up with it so extensively i
don't have uh
i just don't have a a firm opinion on it
you know well i've been keeping up and i
feel so unbelievably annoyed by kanye
these days like to the point where like
i won't finish his documentary even
though i loved part one i just i've been
so inundated with kanye bullshittery
that i'm actually really here i probably
will watch the grammys and now that
kanye's not there like honestly i'm here
for it i'm sorry that makes that big of
a difference to you yeah he's really
[ __ ] annoying me and like honestly he
just keeps going lower and lower and
lower and i'm firmly team kim here i am
okay um
and
what was the other thing i was gonna say
i don't remember but i oh so last week
on friday we reported that there was
this um
petition going around change.org it
hadn't made a lot of waves it had like 5
000 signatures but i'm sure it has more
now petitioning that coachella drop him
as a headliner
so i wonder if that's next but how would
you feel about that i don't know because
i'm not going to coachella so it doesn't
affect me like if i'm paying no pitches
i don't know see i don't know because to
me that's pretty much the same concept
as his not performing at the grammys
just a bigger scale with like why it's
also like an hour performance
yeah no but it's the same thing just
like everything is just bigger about it
yeah but i don't agree with the premise
or not no because people bought tickets
with the intention of seeing kanye and
that's not fair to them like if i spent
a million dollars on a coachella ticket
which is literally what they cost
because i love kanye and then he swapped
out for ariana grande while ariana's
great i paid for kanye yeah even though
i'm not going so that doesn't affect me
and that's why i don't really have an
opinion on it yeah
okay
it's very confusing yeah he's just like
in this terrible place and he has to
step away from the phone yeah i agree
completely with that he needs to get
some perspective he needs to step away
from the phone he needs to spend time
with his family he needs to just take a
back seat for a little while because
well i think he's trying to spend time
with his family and that's why he keeps
going to the phone i don't agree with
that but it's fine you don't think isn't
that why he keeps granting he can't go
yeah
yeah but kim's like he he's talking
about how he hasn't seen his kids in a
week and kim commented you were
literally here this morning to pick him
up for school like so i don't i honestly
i don't believe what kanye says honestly
okay i'm i'm standing firm in my beliefs
okay sounds good i mean i probably
won't watch the grammys anyway i didn't
even realize they were happening i
thought they were canceled
i don't know i can't keep up with the
award show bullshitter i can't and there
is more award show bullshittery coming
up coming up but first because we're
talking about kanye we have to get to
our pete story of the day pete davidson
joined scott disick for a wild boys
night people lost their minds over this
video okay
why because first of all it's like a
video of a bunch of guys watching tv and
they've all clearly fallen asleep except
for the person who's filming so you see
all these guys sleeping and then i'm
like is that scottish and then the
person filming turns the phone around on
them and it's like oh my god it's pete
so you just first of all didn't know who
was behind the camera and it was like
this big shock and then it's like oh my
god scott and peter hanging out got it i
never saw it not knowing that it was
pete who was there yet once like it has
the headlines like then it's like scott
and pete are hanging out which is really
cute also um because
kim was in miami this weekend for skip
which we didn't even get a chance to
talk about i mean i spoke about it with
ben and he like wasn't having the energy
i needed him to um what do you think
about skims doing swim how do you think
it affects kylie swim and were you able
to get anything it sold out in half a
second probably the fastest i've ever
seen anything sell out on skims okay i
feel really good about skim swim because
even when i first got my first pair of
skins that was like the bandeau and the
little shorts i loved how i looked in it
so much that i was like i want to wear
this as a bathing suit
like so i hope that everything about it
is just like those skims pieces that i
liked um
i'm gonna come back to number two
because number three did i get anything
like no i have no idea what size i am or
what size i'm going to be right right
this is not a period of time where i'm
shopping right now even though i should
buy some things because like
getting dressed this morning was really
depressing like my clothes don't fit me
obviously i never bought that many
maternity clothes you'd be like you
really don't look that different like
like crazy the eyes are like nice and
thick like tall no no like it's you
literally look like so average i can't
really explain it to you in any other
way like you don't even look like you
had a baby so
i can't okay well there's definitely
some changes and which is fine and i'm
not like you know putting pressure on
myself or anything but like i had me to
put clothes on and i don't have really
what to wear if i had to notice a change
it would be the size of your breasts
like they're
not as i sit here no no i mean yesterday
you whipped it out right in front of it
like because you yeah but opposing
person in them oh have i seen them
gorgeous anyways when i do know where
i'm at um i would definitely participate
in skim swims they should call it swims
100 and how does it affect kylie swim i
don't think that it does i mean i think
we had the same conversation when she
launched kkw beauty and there was kylie
cosmetics it's like how could we have
two cosmetics companies but even if you
just look at like the styles that they
wear bathing suits that they wear
separately and what they're launching
two completely different
brands i agree kylie's are very like
vegas instagram boat and kim's are very
i think more day-to-day like
staples yeah exactly basics yeah and
that's what skims is i think it's
perfect but also speaking of kylie so hi
oh
girlie how you doing um second of all by
the way and i just love the stories that
you posted about like you know us
ladies oh not putting too much pressure
on ourselves we just created humans a
hundred percent i totally agree we love
you
um another thing i wanted to say was
that when we were discussing skims and
kylie swim with ben he like wasn't
listening but i was saying kylie swim
has been kind of quiet because they
haven't posted on instagram since
october 2021. yeah
guess who posted on kylie swim literally
like two days ago i'm just saying and
someone sent it to me they were like oh
my god you reminded kylie like she has
to post on kylie swim right that's like
me with the redheads exactly passion
projects kylie knows all about passion
projects 100 so i think that now we
should take this opportunity to request
another sign from our
another sign okay do you have a sign in
mind no i don't i think we should
brainstorm because i think while nails
in nature like was a crazy coincidence
it's not she's never posted before like
i think we should maybe go a little bit
more out of the box okay but we can't go
too far else she's not going to do it
because like she's not she has a brand
that she's running she's not just going
to post crazy [ __ ] of course i'm
thinking does she still have dogs like
norman oh my god yeah you didn't see her
stories the other day i think she got a
new dog and then oh and they all are the
same breed and they all were like
flocking towards her it was so cute so
so should we request that even though
she just posted that or something yeah
because she doesn't post them a lot and
she just posted them so she wouldn't be
posting them again unless it was
requested okay so let's request let's
put in a formal request
for some dog content yeah um feel free
to take creative liberty kylie on you
know
where which
but we just would request some videos
yeah we don't care just that's what brew
and you want to see today yeah we're
just the messengers yeah oh my god like
that
i'm like pretty convinced especially we
got like a dm from someone who works you
know
close to kylie giving us some intel um
but i will
like this will be the thing that gets me
like fully on like on the boat and i
just want to say like i was existing no
it was an instinct before and like i
thought i was being like a little crazy
because it was a coincidence you know
she wanted to share the baby's name like
right after i said that i wanted to hear
it um but then after the events of last
week i'm fully convinced and even if she
doesn't post the dogs like because she
might be like i gave you girls a sign if
you don't want to see it right then
that's on youtube if you want to doubt
me right that's like that story of the
guy who's like stranded on an island god
will save me god will save me and the
boat comes and he's like no god will
save me i'm good a helicopter comes and
he's like no god will save me i'm good
and then the man drowns and he goes to
heaven and he was like god why didn't
you save me and god was like i sent you
a boat i sent you a helicopter it should
kind of kind of sent us nature she sent
us nails
so she's like you have your signs i know
but like at this point it's just a fun
game and i think it's fun for her too
like i think she's down if you are
watching please do it for me for claudia
claudia yeah because i'm i would say i'm
76 there okay
and kylie like if you also just want to
like like one of our pictures that would
be a good
thing too like that would be super
helpful like cut straight to the chase
you know she's out of control kylie and
if you want to send me 500 million
dollars that will work too she's out of
control or why don't you send the plane
for us
send kylie and send the boat
helicopter
we'll fly to you and then you can tell
us how much you love the podcast and you
can come up yeah of course okay we're
asking too much yeah no we're uh that
was all joke pictures of dogs that is
our request
okay back to pete and kim he picked her
up from the airport after she got home
from miami and black mercedes and they
kissed yeah yeah very cute and i need to
share my feelings about the ellen
interview oh yeah not only like the
revelation that these two are dating
she's talking about him she's gushing
about him beyond he has multiple tattoos
of her and a brand
i
i don't think i've ever been so
surprised by any bit of news ever
more shocking than them dating in the
first place like nothing says forever
like a brand i know
this is forever and it was actually
pretty funny when ellen was like well
you're all about your brands so yeah no
it's like so yellowstone
and
i was totally floored no i was like i
was having a visceral physical reaction
to the interview because first of all
i've never really seen kim like quake
like that like she was like nervous and
she was being so cute she was just like
you know a girl in like a teenager in a
relationship yeah you know and i thought
she looked
so
insanely special like she was giving pam
anderson like with the hair and the turd
like it was
it was sickening like beyond yeah um so
with these two and i and i'm obsessed
with pete hanging out with scott like
the more he becomes integrated in the
family i feel like a lot of people who
date the kardashians even if it doesn't
end up working out like they miss the
family like they love hanging out with
the family so i just love that pete is
fully immersing himself in the family i
really went from thinking that this was
like a cute rebound to like if they get
don't get married like i will cry yeah
no i think they're gonna maybe be life
partners i don't know if they'll get
married yeah i don't know if pete's the
marrying type and i don't know if kim
wants to get married again
yeah but that works for me me too no
just as long as they're happy and they
seem
over the moon i know which is crazy and
then kim went to miami for this like
sickening swims event that like
was like all the coolest people in the
world just like sitting at one table and
that was cool i was happy for them yeah
but sad for yourself of course
it's hard like would you ever see
things on social media that like in no
universe would you ever be invited to
but like you feel so gutted and like
offended that you weren't invited is
that psychotic um i don't see that about
like
i don't know not necessarily events that
like i would never have been invited to
i don't have like foam over that but
like if i see like a concert or
something that was like in another like
i would never making it there but like
that hurts yeah no i feel like slighted
when i see like sick events that like in
no universe in no
world that we currently live in when i
ever be invited to i'm like i can't
believe i was invited i mean i can't
believe it either no it's disgusting
it's disgusting people need to get their
priorities in order it's so twisted it
ain't right ain't right are you ready
for our next story something else that
may or may not be ain't right okay west
side story's rachel zegler says she
didn't get an invite to the oscars she's
hoping for a last-minute miracle rachel
zegler who is from west side story says
she hasn't been invited to the academy
awards over the weekend she stars as
maria in the remake of west side story
she claimed in a set of comments on
social media that she has not received
an invitation to the awards ceremony
which is scheduled to take place on
sunday the movie is nominated for movie
of the year and typically the cast yeah
the movie of the year nominations get
invited to the oscars so what is going
on here it's definitely bizarre i mean
she wasn't herself nominated but i still
think it's incredibly weird that she
wasn't invited i'll be extremely curious
to see if ansel elgort is well that's
what i think it's about i feel like they
don't want him there and so they didn't
invite her okay so we're blaming
rachel's egg
like i don't know maybe they couldn't
they didn't want to not just invite him
i'll be curious to see more so if the
other movies of the year nominees have
the cast have the cast there who aren't
nominated because say this movie wins
movie of the year which yeah from what i
understand it won't be but then they go
up and accept the award and like she
should be up there but she can't be up
there if she's not invited right no and
if it is because of the ansel elgort of
it all like that's honestly i don't
really think that's what it is what do
you think it is i don't know but like
lost in the mail the oscars like they
had casey affleck they had mel gibson
like they don't give a [ __ ] like they
literally don't give a [ __ ] i think it
took like a hundred years for them to
actually uninvite harvey weinstein like
they don't give a [ __ ] so i don't i
honestly don't think it's about the aunt
laguard of it all i really don't what do
you think it is a smaller affair this
year perhaps i don't i really don't know
because that's really odd yeah and maybe
now that she's you know put it out there
she'll get invited maybe someone an
intern is getting fired i do think like
her motivation behind sharing that she
wasn't now she's like responding to
comments on instagram i do believe it
was like in the hopes of like starting
some sort of movement for herself which
i'd love i'd love a queen who could
stand up for herself i don't know if
it's gonna work like i don't think you
can just get invited to the oscars the
week of like i think it's like
like a whole thing unless there was an
error here yes unless there's a human
error yeah yeah but was ansel invited
because that would that would let us
know whether or not there was an error i
just like if ansel it goes and she's not
there like people are [ __ ] right yeah
that's insane i don't know
i don't know it's pretty like
disrespectful unless the other casts
aren't all there we shall see
yeah i i really don't know why she
wouldn't be invited especially she's
like a young starlet she's on the rise
like
why wouldn't they want her there i don't
know and like if it clearly this movie
isn't gonna like the movie can't win
because it would be bizarre to have them
come accept an award and the cast isn't
there so why is it nominated right right
um i'm really rooting for tammy faye
yeah i'm rooting for the movies i saw of
course except the house of gucci and not
spencer and that's it so that leaves me
with
champagne yeah i don't think it's going
to win though me neither would i
necessarily think it should
i liked it i liked it put it like if
that's the movie of the year like great
agreed it was like a cute fun film
moment like it wasn't like a life
changing you know yeah it's no slumdog
millionaire no but like i think the
movies that are making a lot of buzz are
coda
power of the dogs never seen it i
haven't seen them but that's what i've
been seeing god i got it when i scroll
are you gonna watch oscars i don't know
because i watched the sag awards and
they were okay yeah and we got some
hosts we have amy schumer yeah we have
amy schumer um
wanda sykes and regina hall so
that's something yeah actually i wanted
to even just for the even if it's cringy
like maybe i'll just watch for the
cringe it really just depends on like
what i'm where you're at in life what
harry was like that day yeah exactly
what does he want to watch right it's
not just about me anymore no that's true
right
and he loves siaski
it's gorgeous i feel like you would
watch it and be like
really inspired by the nature
the physiques of all the beautiful women
yeah he definitely loves it he loves it
so much
are you ready for our next story only if
it's a story that's brought to you by
manscaped it is oh it's perfect story
spring has sprung and the sponsors of
today's show manscaped are here to make
sure the house isn't the only thing your
man is spring cleaning i wish my man
would spring clean my house manscape
just recently launched their fourth
generation performance package with all
the tools equipped to tackle that spring
fever in his pants it's time to have him
join the other four million men who
trust manscaped use code toast to get 20
off in free shipping at manscape.com
manscapes are the global leaders in
men's below the way screaming and they
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this ball care bundle he'll
find the lawn mower trimmer the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer the
crop preserver ball deodorant the crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold all the goodies
get 20 off in free shipping with the
code toast at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with code toast at
manscape.com spring is nature's way of
saying let's party so party on with
manscaped um if there's a man in your
life like it's something that you can
purchase and like look like oh look i'm
so nice i was thinking of my boyfriend
but it's really for you as well so get
your man the manscape performance
package you're thinking of yourself you
won't regret it as you should be
our next story drake bell addresses the
josh peck drift why
let's take it from the top
drake bell addresses the josh peck rift
and the drake and josh reboot that
didn't happen
on march 19th drank belle responded to
the recent drama between him and former
drake and josh co-star josh peck last
week the latter said on bff's podcast
that the two were no longer friends and
broke his silence about the angry tweets
striker posted in 2017 about not being
invited to his wedding he also talked
about what allegedly happened between
the two former tv stepbrothers at a
subsequent reunion at the mtv vna vmas
drake bell's wife janet bell had
disputed josh's taken to skating since
deleted instagram story on the inaugural
inaugural house are you okay you want to
read this story no there's just like so
much background somebody explain it
thank you so josh peck who after coming
on the toast is one of the most loved
men in america yes um he was on bff's
pod last week and he was telling the
story because obviously everyone wants
to know about drake josh drake josh and
honestly if you read his book you see
there's it's really not this like big
story like drake was all butt hurt that
josh didn't invite him to his wedding
and josh was like we barely spoke in 10
years after drake and josh between jake
and josh and my wedding so i invite him
to my wedding as you wouldn't invite a
co-worker from 10 years ago who you
barely keep in touch with like it was
really not that big of a deal but drake
i think like thrives
and gets so much attention whenever he
talks about josh so
josh went on bff's pod and said that the
first time he saw drake after those
tweets that he posted during their
wedding was at a vma award and josh went
over to him i was like listen you're
gonna have to apologize to my wife or
like we're gonna have a problem
and drake went over and apologized and
it was fine
i guess drake took some umbrage with the
way josh told that story he was being
like you know josh is a storyteller he
was uh painting a picture for us and
drake said it like wasn't that dramatic
and so drake launched his own podcast
called drake and janet which has the
exact same logo as drake and josh but
it's drake and janet and it's beyond
funny um and him and his wife are just
like ragging on josh and the thing is
maybe i'm feeling overly protective of
josh because he sat here not 72 hours
ago being a [ __ ] precious gem of a
man and i feel as though i know his
heart like i feel as though i do and i'm
a hundred percent believing whatever the
[ __ ] josh peck says second of all it's
like there's two men here one of them is
p john and the others on two years
probation for child endangerment like
you bet your ass i'm going with the
former
also what i did find interesting about
this was that there was a script
floating around that josh had written
um
for a drake and josh reboot that i think
got picked up by someone but it never
ended up going through it because drake
and josh couldn't get along but it was
going to be like one of these reboots
that everyone's doing and it was written
by josh and i'm sure it was really good
yeah wow yeah but it's a no
i mean some things are perfection yeah
and you should leave it at that and i
mean wouldn't megan have been involved
otherwise i don't want it but she's
doing icarly revival she's doing a
million things she's actually megan
she's going viral on tick tock right now
are you aware of it no so she went on
the whitney cummings podcast and i guess
i don't know what the context was but i
assume it was like how she's like very
sweet and innocent and like
she was she says well i actually do cuss
a little
i have heard this and whitney and
everyone is like gagging and they're
like what's your favorite customer and
she's like probably [ __ ] and they're
like
like they're losing their minds that's
so funny i saw someone did a reel with
it yeah
and it's megan that's hysterical yeah
it's really good
um
but back to the drake and josh of it all
like don't get it twisted like here at
the morning toast we stand firmly on
team josh we are literally the captains
of team josh yeah and also like as far
as a reboot goes like if these two are
not like real life step brothers then it
just doesn't work
it just
no and josh is now
starring in a reboot of his own how i
met your mother he's in the how i met
your father reboot and a lot of people
think he might be the father he doesn't
even know like i tried to get the juice
it's like
we don't know yet the show's brand new
yeah no i've seen it it looks good
mm-hmm
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
she's not right i'm not ready hold on
please hold on
everyone get up get a snack maybe turn
the volume a little thing we bring it to
me
sorry i'm completely unprepared i
apologize to everyone
it's okay it gives you time to turn the
volume down you know where's the stick
oh we're missing i mean i could use a
different stick
okay
okay wait the stick is back so i'm sorry
you had asked me a question and
are you ready for the fifth and final
story
yeah
i think i am
it's the final story
[Music]
my favorite one is probably
[ __ ]
and that's a magic number that is such
an endearing quote i do cuss no i know
and if you're calling it cuss you
obviously don't curse a lot my favorite
one is probably
what's your favorite curse word oh
that's such a great question my favorite
scooter
probably [ __ ] yeah no i think that
they're they're all good there aren't
that many though [ __ ] [ __ ] ass are like
the main or the final four yeah um i
guess you could throw in the c word in
there but that's not what they should
use that's insane um yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass ass sucks i do have
to say yeah and [ __ ] is like shitty no
but sometimes like if you stub your toe
like you need a good [ __ ] of course but
like
that's not it's not like what you use in
conversation and i actually think we
should petition i'm gonna start my own
change shadow work petition to remove
[ __ ] from the top four because [ __ ] is
not a [ __ ] curse word like it's not
yeah it's a term of endearment and i
will take that to my grave okay
are you ready speaking of [ __ ] for our
fifth and final story miley cyrus
notices a [ __ ] nick jonas sign during
lollapalooza chili concert 15 years
after they've split well that makes me
feel old 15 years yeah why'd they have
to say that no they didn't have to that
means we're like 30. yeah while
attending miley cyrus's lollapalooza
chili set one fan made at crystal clear
which side of the breakup they supported
the wrecking ball song tris read during
the concert she said [ __ ] nick jonas
then she said i didn't say it i didn't
say it just one of the other signs
um yeah i saw a lot of clips from her
chile
concert going viral on tick tock this
one in particular um
i've had like a actually a really miley
failed weekend
what on friday night me and ben were
just like laying in bed about to go to
sleep and for some reason we started
talking about like miley cyrus's catalog
of music and it just sent me on a spiral
of like breakouts right
right yeah can't be tamed
meet miley cyrus like right before even
bangers was really good but all the [ __ ]
between hannah montana and bangers like
really was
a moment like it was a
a time of my life that like was really
influenced by miley's music um and i was
just like really having a newfound
appreciation for marley and i do rag on
her a lot i have to admit like i do um
and honestly i was watching her chile
performance and i don't know if i would
enjoy a miley cyrus concert i feel like
you would why do you not think so
because every time i've seen her perform
especially at a major festival like all
she does is hold the microphone out for
the crowd to sing like i came to a
concert to see you sing
you are the performer i that's like my
biggest pet peeve like at like the peaks
of songs when the singer will stop and
have the crowd sing like no we suck we
came to see you no my peak is when they
spend so much time talking
and it's like they first of all we
didn't come to hear you talk yeah it's
not stand up i know you say this to
every crowd every night i don't feel
special yeah and that bothers me you
know who does speak a lot and it's all
so rehearsed no but it's okay because
like she fancies herself a comedian
adele well that's not what i was going
to say and
i that was my least favorite part of the
adele concert that i went to at madison
square garden a few years it was full
stand up between but she like has a bit
of stand-up chops it didn't bother me so
much from her no but what i was gonna
say and it pains me to say but like
who's the queen
of talking between songs very lengthy
and extremely verbatim word for word
like from the night before is taylor
swift it's like
it's actually a great time to go to the
bathroom or get a snack or a drink but
yeah i i can't lie like i hate it and
that's
actually what i liked about the john
mayer concert i recently went to like he
did not mince words he didn't even speak
to us like he just played the music i
love that it's just it's it's not the
vibe yeah unless unless we can feel that
like and it's genuine that you're just
like talking just to us yeah and you
didn't say this last night in north
carolina yeah and for some reason like
when certain artists go on tour i get
like stuck in tick tock like
cycles of their content and they really
do do alipa like i'm on her dually but
she says the same thing at every show
like it's
i hate i really hate when people speak
at concerts and i know that's mean it's
like shut up and sing
but like it's just how i feel yeah and
you get like you know about a minute to
introduce a new song you want to tell us
where you're at when you wrote it fine
but like to do a bit
it's not it's not the time no major
shout out to the jonas brothers i don't
think they said one word on stage and i
thoroughly enjoyed that that's nice i
haven't been into a concert in forever
so i can't reference
i think the last one i went to was
celine dion wow yeah right before the
pandemic she didn't say a word either
she just
no she likes to talk she's a talker
actually she has like a funny person she
does and she's like an icon so who are
we to say yeah luke holmes spoke a
little bit but it was just i want to
hear every word i don't care where you
said it and it was really about like how
grateful he was
yeah no i guess it just i must hate the
artist if i don't want to hear them talk
no there's sometimes i love the like
taylor swift i would literally take a
bullet that's true but i'm like girl
please stop talking but i also feel like
luke holmes he's not a man of many words
exactly so when he's speaking you better
[ __ ] listen you sit down and listen
100 take a seat 100
yeah i guess it just depends what was
the story oh miley concerts are more
personal than food it's true they are oh
i was telling sophia i was laughing so
hard
about your more personal when she was
like when someone is going to come for
my podcast that's just what i'm going to
say yeah comedy is more personal than
food podcasts are more they really are
more personal than food i've really
discovered that in the last few weeks of
listening to podcasts this one is the
best one i'm sorry and i'm not even
biased because i was like when toast was
off and i was looking for podcasts like
nothing came close and then last week i
was just laughing through breastfeeding
it's a joy last week was a great week of
shows i hope we could replicate that
this week but i'm so glad to start it
off with you in studio like thank you so
much for being here no i think you're
going to replicate it because you know
the common denominator of all these
great shows is you
you said it not me um also like you're
welcome the way oh yeah thanks
yeah i feel like maui you're welcome
what can i say except you're welcome
um what i was gonna say was honestly i
can't really put into words like how at
ease i feel with you especially because
you're doing the stories like the
tension i hold in my back for the 60
minutes even if it's the best co-host or
the worst co-host knowing i have to
space out the ads read all the stories
keep the conversation going make the
person feel comfortable while also still
being funny and entertaining like
there's really nothing worse i can't lie
it's insanity plus like we're doing this
live really like sure you could cut
something out if you needed to but i
don't you don't cut out awkward silences
right like if this were just a taped
podcast you can make it all sound
seamless even if you take the
awkwardness out right but you can't do
that right we don't edit here at the
morning toast we're unfiltered right
so
now thank you for unburdening yourself
with that
which is the perfect way to dive into
our segment that we just added to the
show that's really becoming a staple
a cornerstone of our show it just fits
right into like all of the things that
we feel here at the morning toes which
is predominantly embarrassment shame
unburden yourselves is a segment where
you guys can write into us and unburden
yourselves with [ __ ] you did over the
weekend that's just like weighing you
down and once you send it into us like
you're officially letting go of it
you're freeing yourself and therefore
unburdening yourself so if you ever want
to write into
our email
the email is unburden yourself
multiple yourselves unburden yourselves
at gmail.com we'll always keep it
anonymous we'll try to make you feel
better about it we will not judge you
for it and it's brought to you by
turbotax people think unusual
circumstances mean complicated taxes but
for turbotax live experts that's what
makes things interesting maybe you
inherited a condo and are renting it out
or maybe you're getting paid in crypto
and you aren't sure how that's taxed for
turbotax live experts an interesting
life can mean an even greater refund and
luckily turbotax live can match you with
the right expert who has experience in
your unique situation and can answer all
of your ques tax questions right from
your phone or computer they even take
care of the whole filing process for you
so whether you launched your own startup
or are working multiple jobs and
juggling multiple incomes an experienced
turbo tax live expert can help you
during the entire filing process or do
your taxes for you from start to finish
to get you the tax
deductions that you deserve visit
turbotax.com to learn more you do your
thing they've got your taxes intuit
turbotax live all right ready ready our
first one's really short a little social
media thing this girl likes to do hi
claudia and jackie sometimes i report
people's instagrams just because i don't
like them
is that why the morning shows instagram
was taken down for a month it was not
but speaking of instagram activity the
funniest thing is happening and we're
doing like nothing about it because it's
the best thing that's ever happened the
morning breath instagram has been
completely hacked it's gone and it's
someone else's living in dubai now and
i'm so happy for him i know he's
obviously like okay first of all if you
don't know what the morning breath is
like it's our old show we have a
verifier and they used to have like 80
000 followers but ever since we switched
to the morning toast we have a new
handle it has like 40 000 and it's
remained dormant for years
and then i went to the email account
like two weeks ago that was associated
with the morning breath instagram and i
saw an email from a couple weeks earlier
i was like oh you changed your email
your password your location everything
i'm like i did
we've been hacked so i didn't really
think anything of it until the person
who hacked it has now become extremely
active yeah and he's having a blast and
you know what someone should enjoy that
i should support him
i have no issue with it it makes me
laugh every time people keep sending it
to me and it's just like we don't know
some people think we sold it which like
i wish we did no we didn't it just has
been hacked and this man's living his
best life
in dubai and he's trying to really
inspire us with his content so the least
we could do is let him yeah but he did
he deleted all the pictures and like for
one day like he only left up a picture
of theo i know but even theo's gonna
change the caption dog
who is like devil emojis i know the only
thing i am like a little sad about is
that like that instagram was full of so
many good clips from our old show that
like don't exist anywhere else yeah like
our halloween episode but you know what
let the man live let the man live like
you can't live in the past no you can't
also what's so funny is we talked about
the fifth and final story about miley
and like didn't talk about our thoughts
on the story at all like yeah no i don't
care like i just think at this point
like
miley's business miley's like
career a lot is like shock value
clickbait and this is like one of those
things like she knew would get picked up
and like i don't care yeah i don't care
about nick jonas honestly no he's
married like
shall we move on yeah we shall move on
and yeah i still i don't know why i
brought it back i still don't have
anything to say
that's actually been like my thoughts on
all five stories like i don't have
anything to say except for kim and peep
on that one right that's all i came here
to talk about today anyways for this
girl she does that's kind of mean but i
think instagram i mean they really have
like the worst security measures
security measures community guidelines
like they're [ __ ] out of control with
their censorship so i was gonna say like
the person there will see that it's not
a real thing and it's just like a funny
thing to do but you know you actually
might be impacting them impacting them i
don't know i if it makes you feel better
like i'm kind of here for it like are
you talking about celebrities or like
your co-worker i think probably like
both and maybe like influencers yeah
you sound like a troll it's kind of
funny but it's mean especially when
someone's like business right like what
are you like reporting people's etsy
shops like let them let them run their
business and put food on the family
table for their family but we didn't
come here to make you feel worse about
what we're doing but just like maybe
keep that in mind the next yeah just
keep in mind like there are consequences
to your actions if you're performing
reporting kim kardashian like nothing's
gonna happen right right right right so
i would need more information on who
exactly you're just i hope it's not us
yeah no we're we love this for you keep
doing it to other people
um okay hey sisters i'm 34 weeks
pregnant so maybe after knowing this
you'll give me a little grace at work i
went and used the bathroom while washing
my hands i saw a few little pieces of
toilet paper left behind and without
noticing the water had risen i flushed
the toilet again
and it overflowed i was mortified uh the
sheer panic of trying to listen to see
if someone was waiting
for the restroom or in the work room to
hear it could have made me bust into
tears i tried to find the janitor to let
her know but i couldn't and there was no
way to tell my office without telling on
myself so i walked out and left it i
know it's a horrible thing to do but i
am so pregnant and your girl just needed
to use the bathroom run like the wind
this is not your problem i i mean
there's nothing else you could have done
and you have so much on your mind on
your plate like on your belly
forget it
yes i forget it like that's what most
people would do like when you walk into
the bathroom and you see that it's
clogged honestly i don't want to know
who clogged it even like yeah because it
changes things it changes things and
instead it's just an anonymous clogged
toilet and you are pregnant and just
move on don't even feel bad about this
one yeah i guess i can't remember a time
when like a toilet's been clogged and
anyone like ran out like i clogged the
toilet we must fix it like it's clogged
toilets are meant to be discovered
anonymously like it's the only way i
agree
or not yeah so i think you totally did
the right thing here yeah yeah it'll get
fixed at some point yeah it's not on you
yeah let someone else be the reporter of
it right you have another quarter didn't
do it of course unless that's a good way
to be sneaky like you clock the toilet
and be like someone clogged the toilet
you they would sniff you out i'm sorry
like it has to be a really good liar
yeah
um okay third and final unburden
yourselves
i hate that this is a true story but i
was at my favorite bar after a big
dinner lots of burritos and queso and
needless to stay my stomach hurt
after a few beers i felt a rumble in my
stomach but i didn't want to leave so i
felt i had no choice but to silently
make a few laps around the bar letting a
few farts loose as i went
unfortunately i ended up being accosted
by the bouncer and actually kicked out
of the bar for crop dusting i will never
have been down no i don't believe this
that's what she says i don't believe she
said the bartender knew and that's
discrimination i even if someone could
sniff you out literally
i don't think that they can kick you out
of a bar for that that is so mean it's
so niche how do they know it's coming
from your ass yeah like without a proper
investigation right even if they could
figure it out like since when is it
illegal to fart you know i have doubts
like you must have been doing something
else worth
worthy of getting kicked out of a bar
because again crop dusting is
essentially a victimless crime
essentially i disagree and there's no
foolproof way to find out who the
originator of the crop dusting is well
if if someone was like on
tracing your scent technically like you
know maybe they discovered someone
starting and then they they keep
following it but it's impossible to
trace a fart like for like 100 like
validate who was farting i just feel
like you know
the rules of to join society these days
are just getting too crazy you know yeah
i agree like you can't fart right
no like bars are gross like their floors
are sticky there's vomit everywhere like
really now we're taking moral high
ground on farting but i just want to say
like if i were there and someone was
going around farting the entire time
like i would have reported you to the
bouncer just right that i would have
launched a full-fledged i don't want to
like i don't want this to be
something that more people feel
empowered to do right why not go to just
the stall and fart like the bathroom
because she would have been there all
night
why not just go home yeah or that's why
you always got to carry gas acts it's a
miracle drug yeah sometimes like you got
to call it a night at some point yeah
and that was your body's way of telling
you let's go home
yeah
you have to listen to your body yeah do
not listen to all the influencers who
tell you that
what are you doing if you're not
listening listen to your body
um okay well thanks for burning
yourselves guys i hope you feel better i
definitely don't um and that's our show
yeah but we now carry the burden and
that's what we can do for you yeah
that's actually like one of the
the hardest parts of our job that we
don't really talk about is like the
mental um anguish that comes with
letting people bird unburden themselves
onto you happy to do it happy to do it i
have a splitting headache you do yeah
this whole time i didn't want to
complain no well someone actually asked
on the patreon and they never um
they asked it after i had done the
episode with you how your migraines are
doing postpartum so like up until right
now i wouldn't have considered these
headaches and migraine it's just from
like lack of sleep but like now it's
like in one center of my and we have so
many breaths and it's coming down into
my eye i think this might be a migraine
i need to see if i can take my migraine
meds if i even have any okay well we'll
let you go thank you so much for being a
selfless queen you're so welcome so fun
to be on this amazing show tomorrow oh
we've got the gals on the go brook
brook and danielle are joining me in
studio so that'll be really exciting and
maybe you can get an update on your
sister from them you know they see her
more than you that's part of the reason
i invited them on the show just to
really get an inside scoop on what's
going on with my sister yeah i'm so
excited for that episode thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast fast stories that
you yes you need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast we're also available as podcasts
anywhere podcasts we found that spotify
itunes central public review all the
places so whatever you listen to
podcasts find out more intellectually
flat story better than all signings
hope you guys have an amazing monday
rise and grind
the society season two if you're still
listening to the end of this episode
congratulations why don't you go drop a
picture on an emoji on our most recent
instagram of a dog in honor of kylie
hopefully posting her dog so go drop
that emoji if you're still listening
thank you so much for being a true
toaster we love you guys and we'll see
you tomorrow bye bye
you